RONALD SMITH: The announcements are
there's a problem set due
today, and
you'll be starting a
new lab next week.
Be sure to bring your laptop to
lab on Monday and Tuesday.
This is a mostly a
computer-based data analysis
type lab, and you're going to
need your laptop from the very
beginning of that exercise.
Any questions before we start?
I'm going to go over the
exam first thing here.
Ok, so problem one, I
show you a top view
of a Focault pendulum.
So imagine you're looking
down at this thing.
And the bob is swinging back
and forth on this line.
So just kind of looking
down like this.
I asked you to sketch the forces
on the bob and explain
how the track will rotate if
the pendulum is in the
Southern Hemisphere.
So in the Southern Hemisphere,
Coriolis force acts to the
left of the motion vector.
So when that bob is moving
upwards on this blackboard,
the Coriolis force is going
to be in that direction.
And when it's moving in the
other direction, the Coriolis
force is going to
be like that.
So the Coriolis force shifts
depending on the direction the
bob is moving.
So what is that going to
do to the plane in
which the bob is swinging?
Well this part when it's
swinging that way it's going
to deflect it a little
bit like that.
And then when it's swinging back
and this force acts on
it, it's going to deflect it
a little bit like that.
And then that's going to repeat
that way and then that
way and then that way.
So basically the plane in which
the bob is rotating is
going to rotate in the
counterclockwise direction.
So if you came back several
hours later and it started out
here, now it's going to be
oscillating like that.
And, of course, if we were in
the Northern Hemisphere, it
would be the opposite.
It would rotate in the
clockwise direction.
Questions on that?
Yes.
STUDENT: What does CCW mean?
PROFESSOR: Counterclockwise.
Is that something the
TA put on there?
STUDENT: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
STUDENT: I said it
was to the left.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
See left is a little bit
ambiguous because what does
left mean here?
I don't know.
OK, question two.
Explain how cool winds and a
gust wind are created by a
thunderstorm.
So the basic idea there is you
get rain coming out of the
base of the cloud.
You know that below the cloud,
the relative humidity
is less than 100%.
So as soon as that rain falls
below cloud base, it's going
to begin to evaporate.
Now maybe only a small fraction
will evaporate, maybe
all of it will evaporate.
I remember when I used to live
in Colorado, you'd see--in the
summertime you'd see
thunderstorms, deep convective
storms, with the rain coming out
of the base, and it would
all evaporate.
None of it reached the
surface of the Earth.
When you see that, by the way,
when it doesn't reach the
surface here, it's
called virga.
But in any case, whether it all
evaporates or just some of
it, it takes heat to evaporate
water, and so--and that heat
comes out of the air.
So there's a cooling that takes
place, an evaporative
cooling that takes place just
below the cloud base, and that
takes air and makes it cooler
and more dense.
So it then falls out of the sky
until it hits the surface,
and then spreads out.
And the front of that is
called the gust front.
So the basic idea here is that
evaporation of raindrops below
the cloud base cools the air,
makes it sink and spread out.
So that's the idea behind if
you've experienced this in the
summertime, you hear a
thunderstorm in the distance,
and then for a few minutes
later the wind
begins to pick up.
It'll be a cool wind, typically,
and blowing from
the direction of the
thunderstorm.
That's this.
That's that cool air
coming down from
the base of the cloud.
Questions on that?
Question three.
I give you 45 degrees north.
There's a pressure gradient,
0.002 Pascals per meter, with
pressure increasing towards the
west. So on a map view,
north, south, east, west, the
question states that the
pressure is greater towards
the west because it's high
pressure over here relative to
low pressure over there.
The lines of constant pressure,
if you drew them in,
the isobars would be oriented
north-south like that.
An air parcel sitting in there
is going to feel a pressure
gradient acting from
high to low.
So that's the pressure
gradient force.
And if we can assume that the
air is in geostrophic balance,
the Coriolis force must be equal
and opposite to that.
We're in the Northern
Hemisphere, 45
degrees north latitude.
So if the Coriolis force is like
that, the wind must be
such that the Coriolis force
is at right angles to the
wind, and to the right
of the wind.
So there's only one possible
solution for the wind, and
that would be that vector.
So that the Coriolis
force is to the
right of the wind motion.
So, well I'm getting ahead of
the story, this is part B. But
basically, the velocity
direction would
be towards the south.
You could state that as a
northerly wind if you wanted,
but the direction will
be towards the south.
Now, the magnitude of the
geostrophic wind is given by
the pressure gradient
divided by 2 rho
omega sine of the latitude.
So let's put in some
numbers on that.
It's 0.002, 2 the density of air
at sea level is about 1.2
kilograms per cubic meter.
The rotation rate of the
Earth is 7.27 times 10
to the minus 7.
And the sine of 45 degrees
is about 0.71.
So that turns out to be 16.2
meters per second.
I would recommend you notice
I left off the units, but I
don't recommend that.
If you put the units for
everything, Pascals per meter,
kilograms per cubic meter,
seconds to the minus 1, you
can work it out and you
should get units of
speed meters per second.
And if you don't, maybe you've
left out something.
Maybe you've got the units wrong
or you've left out a
factor or something like that.
So it's always good to check
the units on that.
For part C, again, what you've
assumed is geostrophic
balance, which says that the
Coriolis force and the
pressure gradient force are
equal and opposite.
That is the definition of
geostrophic balance.
Yeah.
STUDENT: Is the rotation rate
10 to the minus 7 or 10
to the minus 5?
PROFESSOR: 10 to the
negative sorry, this is wrong.
10 to the minus 5.
Thank you.
If you ever I mean I gave you
that constant on the equation
sheet, but if you ever need it
and can't remember it, just
take 2 pi, which is the number
of radians in a circle, and
divided it by the length of a
day expressed in seconds.
And you'll get that number, 7.27
times 10 to the so it's
just the rotation rate of the
Earth basically, expressed in
radians per second.
Four.
Explain why the sky appears
blue, but a cloud appears
white under similar illumination
from the Sun.
So the idea is we have
our observer.
We have a cloud here.
And the Sun is illuminating the
cloud, but is also seeing
radiation that's been scattered
I don't have to draw
another beam there.
Some light is scattered out of
this beam coming directly to
the observer, and that's
blue light.
But this is white light.
So the difference has to do with
the size of the particles
that are doing the scattering.
In the case of the sky, the
particles are molecules.
And the condition that the
wavelength is much, much
greater than the diameter of the
particle is met, and that
puts us into the Rayleigh
scattering regime.
In that case, short wavelengths
are scattered much
more strongly than longer
wavelengths.
Remember, the part of the
spectrum we can see with our
eye, the visible part
of the spectrum has
red, green and blue.
Blue being the shorter.
Red being the longer
wavelength.
So in Rayleigh scattering where
short wavelengths are
scattered more strongly, that'll
be the blue light
that's scattered more than
the green and the red.
So this light scattered out of
the Sun's beam to your eye by
molecules is going to be
dominated by the blue light.
For the cloud itself, the
particles are much larger.
They're the cloud droplets.
They fall into the category
that the wavelength is the
same order of magnitude
as the cloud droplet.
Which puts us into the Mie
scattering range where all
wavelengths are scattered
equally.
So whatever color was
illuminating this, you'd have
the same color coming out.
So if it's white light
illuminating the cloud, and
the Sun's radiation is usually
composed of roughly equal
mixtures of blue, green and
red, so that would appear
white to our eye.
Then the light scattered
by the cloud is
also going to be white.
By the way, if you have a
setting Sun illuminating the
cloud where some of the blue
light has already been
scattered out, it may
be that the cloud is
illuminated by red light.
In that case, the cloud would
appear red as well.
But the point here is that
under Mie scattering, it
scatters equally whatever is
illuminating the cloud.
So it'll keep the color the same
as it scatters radiation
from the cloud.
Questions there?
Question five.
Why are hurricanes not found
over the sea near the equator?
Well right near the equator
within four or five degrees of
the equator, there's not
sufficient Coriolis force.
In order to form a hurricane, as
the air moves in and begins
to lift upwards, there's got to
be a Coriolis force to give
it a sense of spin.
And if you don't have a
sufficient Coriolis force,
then you can't really
form a hurricane.
Part B, in the tropical
south Atlantic.
So let's assume you're south of
the Equator enough to have
a Coriolis force, but it turns
out in the Atlantic Ocean,
there's a cold current that
comes up from the southern
ocean that drops the ocean
temperature below that
threshold value it's 27,
28 degrees Celsius, and
therefore, you don't
have the ocean
warmth to create a hurricane.
Questions there?
Question six I thought
was straightforward.
Basically is why water drops
form on the outside of a cool
glass of water?
So you've got cold water or cool
water in there at some
temperature.
And you want to know when beads
of water would form on
the outside.
Well, of course the water is
not coming from inside the
glass through the glass, that
water is coming from the
atmosphere around.
The only role of the water in
the glass is to control the
temperature of the outer
surface of the glass.
And the key condition is that
the temperature of that glass,
if it's less than the dew point
of the atmosphere around
it, then you will get
condensation.
The idea is that the glass will
remove heat from the air
adjacent to it, drop the
saturation vapor pressure
down, and if it can drop it low
enough, it can drop the
temperature down below the dew
point, then you'll bring water
out of the vapor state and
condense it on the
outside of the glass.
So I was looking for a clear
explanation of that.
Question seven.
How do the raindrops form that
we find falling from a tall
cumulonimbus cloud?
In the summertime you get tall
cumulus clouds with heavy rain
out the bottom.
The fact that they're tall means
that the top part of it
is certainly going to be at a
temperature lower than zero
degrees Celsius.
So there's going to be super
cooled water up here.
And that's going to be the key
for generating precipitation.
So using the ice phase mechanism
then you can convert
these to snowflakes.
They'll fall, when they fall
below the zero degree line,
they'll melt and form raindrops
and then they'll
fall to Earth.
So what you had to say there
was to mention, at least
mention, the ice phase mechanism
because that's how
the hydrometer would
be formed.
And then you had to describe how
it would melt on the way
down to form a raindrop.
Question 8.
I imagine on the Earth some air
moving northward with a
temperature of 20 degrees C, and
some air moving southward
with a degree of--with a
temperature of 10 degrees C.
And I asked you to compute
how much heat is
being transported northward.
The idea there is that the heat
transported is given by
the rate I'll put a dot over it
to indicate it's a rate the
rate at which you're moving mass
forward times and heat
capacity of the air times well,
if it's a two stream
difference and you want to
compute the net amount of
heat, then you'd use the
temperature differences
between the two streams.
That's the
way I did the problem.
So my answer for this was 10 to
the eleventh kilograms per
second for the mass flow rate,
and that was given.
The heat capacity of air is
1,004, and that has units of
Joules per kilogram
per degree Kelvin.
And then the temperature
difference between the two
streams, the delta-T
was 10 degrees.
And look how the units are
going to work there.
This is going to be in Kelvin
or Celsius, in either case
it'll cancel.
The kilograms will cancel, and
you get something with Joules
per second, which is
a watt, by the way.
So I ended up with what did
I get 1.5 times 10 to the
seventeenth oh sorry.
Let's see, about 1.004 times
10 to the fifteenth watts,
which could be expressed as
about 1.004 petawatts.
Peta meaning the shortcut
for 10 to the fifteenth.
So it's approximately 1 times
10 to the fifteenth watts.
Now, there was some confusion
because while I described
these two air masses moving
northward and southward, in
the end I said how much heat
is transported northward.
What I meant to say, what I
hoped you would interpret that
is the net amount transported
northwards.
And that's what I've
computed here.
It may be, though, that some
of you computed just the
amount of heat transported
northward by the northward
moving current.
Maybe that could be supported
given by the
way I wrote the question.
But what I intended was the net
heat given the fact that
there's both a northward and a
southward block of air moving.
So look at the grading and see
what the TAs did about that.
Questions there?
We're getting close
to the end here.
Question nine says that on a
rainy day a centimeter of rain
falls on a 10,000 square
kilometer area.
Estimate the total
latent heat.
So you imagine some big cloud
system raining out, putting a
layer of water on the surface
of the Earth.
You just have to compute the
volume of that layer.
Then from the volume multiplied
by the density of
fresh water to get the
mass of that layer.
And then knowing the latent heat
of condensation, you know
how much heat had to be released
in order to condense
that much vapor to a liquid.
So from the mass you just
multiply that by the latent
heat of condensation.
So the dimensions of this give
the volume, the mass--the
density of water, which is
1,000 kilograms per cubic
meter gives you the mass.
And then the latent heat of
condensation gives you the
rest. And the answer is about
1.5 times 10 to the
seventeenth joules.
STUDENT: 2.5.
PROFESSOR: Sorry, 2.5.
Thank you.
That 2.5 comes from
the latent heat.
Thank you.
The last problem then was to
explain the reason for the
rainy season in these
two cities.
Jerusalem lies here.
And Asuncion, Paraguay, except
it shifted in longitude occurs
somewhere here.
Now, Jerusalem has a--it's in
the Northern Hemisphere.
Wettest month is January, and
notice from the temperatures,
that's also the cooler month.
So Jerusalem gets a wintertime
rainy season, and that is
clearly due to the southward
shift of the polar front.
So what's happened is that
during the winter season, this
polar front has moved southward
and is giving you
frontal cyclones that come
through that latitude and give
you the rain.
In Asuncion, Paraguay, Southern
Hemisphere, the
wettest month is December.
In the Southern Hemisphere
that's summertime.
Notice also from the temperature
that that's the
warmer month.
So you know immediately
that is a summertime
precipitation maximum.
And that guarantees that it's
going to be a southward shift
of the ITCZ, giving you
precipitation there.
So the ITCZ in the Southern
Hemisphere summer moves across
the Equator into the Southern
Hemisphere and brings
precipitation to Asuncion.
So that's going to be convective
rain, not frontal
rain, and it's going to be
in the summer wet season.
Any questions on that?
The average grade on that
exam was a bit lower
than the first one.
It was 74%.
And if you've got maybe 10
degrees--10 degrees--10 points
lower than that, maybe drop me
a note, come see me, we'll
talk about how to improve
things in the future.
But for some reason, the grades
were a little bit lower
on this than the other one.
And take that into account when
you're don't be overly
critical of yourself, because
apparently your classmates
found that to be a tough
exam as well.
We're going to continue
where we left off.
Question, yes?
STUDENT: I was wondering what
the average score corresponds
to in grade?
PROFESSOR: I don't do
that calculation until the
end of the course.
I keep them just as numerical
scores until
the end of the course.
You can judge that for yourself,
perhaps, based on
the average grade.
But that's not a calculation
that I do until I get all the
scores at the end.
So we're talking about
atmospheric forcing of the
ocean, and I showed this
slide last time.
I'll just go back over it.
Basically the ocean is driven by
the atmosphere above it in
these three ways.
Heat added, and taken away,
fresh water added and taken
away, and the wind stress.
We can quantify this, and recent
investigators have
tried to do this by producing
maps, in this case, of the
heat flux in and out of the
ocean, or the water flux in or
out of the ocean, or the
wind stress applied
to the ocean surface.
So we know a bit about
this forcing.
And last time I derived some
formulas for this, how a layer
of depth D, which will feel
the direct effect of this
forcing, would respond
to fresh water,
heat, or wind stress.
I won't go back over those
derivations, but for the wind
stress, which is I think the
most difficult of the three,
the concept involved
this Ekman layer.
When the wind blows over the
ocean and puts a frictional
stress on it, the first few tens
of meters or hundreds of
meters responds to that
directly, but in an odd way.
It moves off well, it has
a spiral with depth.
I'm not going to talk
about that.
But if you average that out, the
net of all that motion is
directly to the right
of the wind stress.
That's this big arrow here.
That's the direction of Ekman
transport, exactly at right
angles to the wind stress
that's being applied.
So if you had a wind, say,
from the southwest to the
northeast, giving you wind
stress in that direction
that's the black arrow and you
gave it a few hours to come
into this new state of balance
called the Ekman force
balance, that force would be
balanced by the Coriolis
force, and if that's going to
be the Coriolis force, then
the Ekman transport must
be in that direction.
So the CF is at right angles
to the net Ekman transport.
Now, this is not identical with
the geostrophic balance.
Remember, geostrophic balance
was a balance between Coriolis
force and pressure
gradient force.
I have no pressure gradient
force in this problem.
This instead is a balance
between a frictional stress
being applied to the ocean,
and the Coriolis force.
But it's very real.
I mean you can measure this
easily in the ocean.
If the wind is blowing briskly
from one direction you can
measure the surface
water moving off
in the right direction.
I'll mention this
in a week or so.
The same thing applies
to icebergs.
When the wind blows on an
iceberg, it moves at right
angles to that force.
The old sea captains
would make notes of
that in their log.
Winds are from the south today,
but the icebergs are
moving off to the east.
What's going on there?
Well, you guys know, it has to
do with this kind of a balance
including the Coriolis force.
So again, not the same as
geostrophic balance, but they
both involve the Coriolis force
in an important way.
These are the formulas that
I derived last time.
If you added an amount of heat
per unit area Q over A, you
can compute how the temperature
of some depth D
will change.
If you add a layer of fresh
water to the ocean of
thickness little d, and then you
mix that in to some layer
of depth D, there's how the
salinity will change.
If you put a wind stress tau
on the ocean, and that is
mixed down to depth d, that's
what the speed will be of that
Ekman flow that goes off
at right angles.
Yeah.
STUDENT: In the Ekman wind
stress, is the rho--
in the denominator is that the
density of water or air?
PROFESSOR: Correct.
Correct.
Water.
I left off the subscript, but
that should be water.
when you're computing tau,
however, I gave you
a formula for tau.
It was rho u squared.
That was the density of air,
and the speed of the wind.
So in the formula for tau that
I gave you, it's the density
of air that appears there.
But down to the bottom here it's
the density of sea water.
STUDENT: So they don't
divide out?
PROFESSOR: No because
there a factor of a
thousand different.
STUDENT: OK.
PROFESSOR: The density of air
at sea level is about 1.2
kilograms per cubic meter.
The density of sea water's
about 1,000 kilograms per
cubic meter.
Yeah.
STUDENT: Just real quick again,
the little d versus big
D, the big D is the
depth and--
PROFESSOR: D--in all
cases, D is this layer that is
feeling the direct influence
of these forcings.
And it's hard to predict exactly
what that'll be.
It'll depend on how much
turbulence there is, how deep
things are going to get mixed.
But it's something very
small compared to
the total ocean depth.
It may be only a few tens of
meters if the winds are weak,
and there's not much
turbulence.
It could be 100 meters or 200
meters if the winds are very
strong and you're mixing the
ocean very vigorously.
So I can't give you a fixed
value for d, it'll depend on
conditions.
Good questions there.
So if those are our three
forcings, then what do they do
to the ocean?
Well the first two, the heat
and the fresh water input,
will modify the temperature
and the salinity.
The temperature and salinity
will in turn change the
density of the seawater.
And then gravity will act on
those density differences to
produce currents down
in the ocean.
And those currents are called
thermohaline currents.
The name reminds you is they
have to do with heat and salt.
But they're acting through the
role of heat and salt in
controlling seawater density.
Typically these currents
are slow and deep.
As I will show you in the next
few minutes, they are
responsible for the water mass
distributions in the ocean,
for the conveyor belt
circulation, and for example,
also for estuary circulation.
So these are very important
circulations in the ocean,
even though they tend to be
rather slow in the speed of
their motions.
These are the thermohaline
currents.
So let's take a look at the
Atlantic Ocean along this
section of 25 west longitude.
Here is a temperature section
given where this goes north to
south, sea level down
to 6,000 meters.
And the black is the terrain.
Now, the first thing that
strikes you about this image
perhaps is the steepness
of this terrain.
Oh my goodness, are there really
these sharp spikes and
cliffs in the ocean?
And the answer is please
remember that when you make a
diagram like this, there is a
lot of vertical exaggeration.
For example, that distance is 5
kilometers or 6 kilometers,
whereas this distance is
something like 15,000
kilometers.
So there is really an enormous
vertical exaggeration.
Where I could squish this down
or stretch this out, these
supposedly steep slopes would
become very, very gradual.
Probably only 1% or 2% slopes.
So don't be fooled by this.
It's only the vertical
exaggeration that gives you
that apparent steepness.
Now, for the temperature itself,
you can't read the
labels very well, but some of
these are slightly negative,
temperature of minus 0.02--sorry
0.2 or 0.4.
If I've got a temperature of
minus 0.4 Celsius, is that
super cooled water?
Is that super cooled water?
How many think yes?
Show of hands.
How many think no?
The danger of putting no up,
I'm going to ask you why.
Why don't you think that's
super cooled water?
STUDENT: Is it because
it has salt in it?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So it's not super cooled water
because the salt actually
depresses the sea level
by a degree or two.
So in fact, you can have a
temperature down to maybe
minus 1 or 1 1/2 degrees
Celsius, and still be above
the freezing point because the
salt has suppressed the
freezing point slightly.
So this is not super
cooled water.
It's not about to freeze if you
introduce some kind of a
freezing nucleus to
it or something.
I want you to notice this band
of blue coming down here.
We're going to identify that
as Antarctic Bottom Water.
It's very cold water that's
formed where the ice sheets
from Antarctica float out
over the ocean and
cool the ocean down.
And that water becomes so cold
and so dense that it falls to
the bottom of the ocean and
then spreads northward.
In this diagram it reaches
the Equator.
Depending--in some other
sections, it actually gets a
little bit north
of the Equator.
This is amazing.
So a water mass formed under the
ice shelves of Antarctica
falls to the bottom of the
ocean, and then under its own
weight slowly moves, sinking
and spreading, actually in
some cases getting north
of the Equator.
That's Antarctic Bottom
Water, AABW.
One of the important water
masses in the Atlantic Ocean
is the AABW.
There is a layer of warm water
floating right on the top in
the tropical and equatorial
regions.
And there are some other water
masses up in here that will be
a little bit easier to identify
when we look at the
salinity field.
So let me look at the
salinity field here.
Atlantic salinity, and 34.7,
34.9, and so on.
The Antarctic Bottom Water you
can maybe see it there, but
it's not as easily seen in
the temperature field.
But look at this thing.
There's a tongue.
Apparently, a water mass is
being formed here in the
Antarctic Ocean so sorry,
in the Southern Ocean.
Not close to the shores of
Antarctica, but in the
southern Ocean.
It sinks and then it spreads
northwards as a tongue, again,
reaching the Equator.
Actually going a little bit
north of the Equator.
That's called the Antarctic
Intermediate Water, AAIW.
There's also a water
mass here.
It's formed in the
North Atlantic.
It sinks and it spreads
southward getting
south of the Equator.
That's the North Atlantic Deep
Water, NADW, North Atlantic
Deep Water.
So what's going on in
all of these cases?
At the surface of the ocean
where the atmosphere and the
ocean touch, the atmosphere
is imprinting a certain
temperature salinity
characteristic to the water.
That determines the
water's density.
That water will then sink down
to its appropriate density
level and spread out.
That was a case for the
Antarctic Bottom Water, the
Antarctic Intermediate
Water, and the north
Atlantic Deep Water.
Notice, their roots all go back
to the surface of the
ocean, because that's where they
can get their properties.
They get the temperature from
the heat fluxes, they get
their salinity from the fresh
water fluxes, and then they
sink and they spread out and
they're found thousands of
kilometers away from where they
were formed, and moving
very slowly there under the
direction of these currents.
Oxygen doesn't play any role
in how these water masses
move, but they provide
a good tracer.
Here's dissolved oxygen,
and you find the
lowest values here.
And notice this curious
structure.
Right at the ocean surface, of
course, you find the highest
values of oxygen.
Well, the oxygen is being taken
in from the atmosphere,
mixed down a couple of hundred
meters, and then following
that water mass here it is
following the north Atlantic
Deep Water, here it is following
the Antarctic
Intermediate Water
right there.
But surprisingly, the lowest
oxygen is in the tropics, just
below the--not touching the
atmosphere, but just below it.
So there's not a very good
communication or mixing
between the surface of the ocean
and this water or it
wouldn't have that
depleted oxygen.
The reason why there is not
strong communication there is
because it's very stable.
There's a thermocline there,
just like an inversion in the
atmosphere prevents
vertical mixing.
So you get this strongly
depleted oxygen water here, so
close to its oxygen source, but
yet cut off by this stable
inversion preventing
vertical mixing.
So we can--
Yeah, question.
STUDENT: Is the oxygen depleted
there because
organisms use it up?
PROFESSOR: Organisms
use as soon as the water
leaves I should have said this,
thanks Julia as soon as
the water leaves the surface
it begins to lose oxygen
because animals use it up, and
respiration takes place to use
up the oxygen.
So the older the water is, the
less oxygen it has in it.
STUDENT: And so the fact that
the oxygen can mix more deeply
in other regions of the world,
does that mean that it won't
be used up as--
PROFESSOR: No, it
might mean that, but it might
just mean that that water has
been down there a longer
period of time.
So the cartoon then of the
Atlantic Ocean, the same
north-south section I've been
telling you about, south to
north, looks like this.
You've got this warm surface
water heated by the Sun kind
of floating, it's
quite shallow.
You've got the Antarctic
Intermediate Water coming in
here, you've got the North
Atlantic Deep Water, and then
you've got the Antarctic
Bottom Water.
Eventually they lose their
characteristics.
They mix in with their
environments, but for at least
hundreds, maybe thousands of
kilometers, during their
transport, they retain enough of
their property that we can
identify them by where their
source region was.
So this is the concept
of the water mass.
In oceanography we have this
concept of the water mass.
It's a mass of water obtaining
its temperature, salinity
properties at the air-sea
boundary, and then sinking and
moving slowly, and for years
retaining that property until
eventually it mixes in
with its environment.
And these motions are
driven by these slow
thermohaline-driven currents.
Questions on this?
So this is the concept of the
water mass in oceanography.
It's a bit like the concept of
the air mass in meteorology
where on a day like this, cool,
brisk, I can say maybe
this is a Canadian air mass.
It got its dryness, its cool
temperatures in Canada, now
it's moved down to me in New
England, but I know from its
properties where it came from.
Whereas a couple days from now
if it's really moist and humid
and warm, likely that's
Caribbean air coming up from
the Caribbean transported to my
location, retaining some of
the properties it acquired
when it was down
in the lower latitudes.
So the concepts are roughly
similar to each other.
Now, I wanted to show you a
famous thermohaline current
called the conveyor
belt circulation.
I wanted to show this diagram
again you've seen it before to
remind you that the Atlantic
Ocean is slightly saltier than
the Pacific, and slightly
cooler than the Pacific,
mostly just saltier.
But as a result, the Atlantic
Ocean--look at the density
numbers--The Atlantic Ocean
water is on average slightly
denser than the Pacific Ocean.
So imagine you've got these
two oceans, OK, they're
separated by North and South
America, but they have
different densities.
If there's any leak between the
two of them, that's going
to try to equilibrate by setting
up a circulation
between them, and that exactly
is what we think happens to
give this large scale conveyor
belt circulation.
Notice that in the Pacific
Ocean, the
water is less dense.
It seems to rise and then
flow into the Atlantic.
The Atlantic Ocean being
somewhat denser, this water
sinks, and then flows on the
bottom of the ocean back into
the Pacific.
So there's kind of an
overturning circulation.
Now OK, it has to go through a
very circuitous route because
they're not directly
connected.
They can't make their way across
this barrier or across
this barrier.
But they do share the southern
Ocean in common.
So they can communicate and
close this circulation by
running the currents down
through the Southern Ocean.
That's the conveyor
belt circulation.
Another example of a slow
thermohaline circulation.
A third example is the
estuary circulation.
An estuary is defined as a
semi-enclosed body of water
with some connection
to the ocean, and
with fresh water inputs.
Long Island Sound would be
a good example of that.
There are fresh water inputs
the Connecticut River, the
Quinnipiac River that we
studied, the Housatonic River.
And there is a connection to
the ocean that goes out
through the race here so
that you can mix ocean
water in and out.
What we find is that while the
ocean salinity is typically 35
parts per thousand, the salinity
in Long Island
Sound's only about 20
parts per thousand.
I think in your field trip you
found 18, but generally that's
pretty close to this.
So what's happening is it's a
place where mixing occurs
between fresh water coming off
the land and ocean water
mixing in from the ocean.
So remember, salty
water is denser.
Fresher water is less dense.
So what happens is that the
denser, fully salt ocean water
slides in along the bottom, has
fresh water added to it,
making it less dense so it
rises, and then it floats out
on the top.
So right through here there's
going to be a two-layer
circulation.
It's illustrated up here with
the fresh water being added,
and that slightly reduced
salinity water flowing out of
the top, and the full
ocean water
flowing in at the bottom.
So you get a two-layer
circulation right at the
entrance region to an estuary,
driven by this salinity
difference.
That would be called a
thermohaline circulation.
Does everybody get that?
What's driving it?
So if I turned off these rivers
in some magical way,
and let the mixing continue,
after a few months, this would
come up to 35 parts
per thousand.
It's the fresh water inputs
that's keeping this
lower than the 35.
And it's that two-layer
circulation that's providing
the mixing between the estuary
and the open ocean.
Questions there?
Yeah.
STUDENT: So it's still called a
thermohaline, even though in
this case it's just driven
by salinity?
PROFESSOR: True.
Because you still got the
haline part of it.
So it would still be called
thermohaline.
The Mediterranean Sea has one of
these, but it works just in
the opposite direction.
Remember, the Mediterranean
Sea is, especially in
summertime, a very
dry climate.
It doesn't rain there, and
there's an excess of
evaporation over
precipitation.
Even when you include the rivers
that flow into it,
there's an excess of
evaporation over
precipitation.
So it becomes saltier than
the ocean itself.
And there is a connection.
It's the Straits of Gibraltar.
That little narrow connection
between Spain and Morocco that
allows some exchange to occur.
Just remember now, in this case,
the Mediterranean water,
while it's fairly warm, the
salt outweighs that.
It's a denser water mass.
So here's a cross section
through the Straits of
Gibraltar, and here's the
Mediterranean Sea in the ocean.
So that dense, salty water
flows out on the bottom,
because it's denser, and the
ocean water at 35 parts per
thousand flows in on the top.
A two-layer circulation driven
by the salt difference.
Just remember, it's opposite in
a sense to the estuary that
I showed you just before this.
This has a place in
the history books.
In both World Wars, the German
U-boat captains knew about
this, and the British had set
up a sonar listening station
at Gibraltar to listen for the
engines of U-boats trying to
get in and out of the
Mediterranean Sea.
But the U-boats captains
realized they could come out
to this place, drop down about
100 meters, turn off their
engines, and then just drift
silently past the British into
the Mediterranean.
Then they could start their
engines, sink a few ships, and
when they wanted to come back
home, they would come over
here, sink a bit deeper, turn
off their engines, and this
current would take them back out
into the Atlantic past the
British sonar station.
So this was known at the
time, and it was used
in a military fashion.
Questions on that?
Now, we've got to get to the
wind driven currents.
We won't get very far on it
today, but I wanted to alert
you to the complexity
of this subject.
We've got to think of a chain
of events that occurs as to
how the wind generates the
major ocean currents.
And there are four
bullets to this.
The wind stress acts
on the ocean as
the frictional stress.
That generates an Ekman layer,
which moves water off at right
angles to the wind stress.
That Ekman layer air flow then
piles up water in certain
parts of the world ocean,
giving a little bit of
elevation variation.
We call that ocean topography.
It's not large, it's only a
few centimeters or tens of
centimeters, but it's
very important.
And then that ocean topography,
through the
hydrostatic law, sets up
horizontal pressure gradients
in the ocean.
If the water's heaped up here
and a little lower here,
you're going to have higher
pressure under the heaped up
water, lower pressure under
the lower water.
So you're going to have a
horizontal pressure gradient.
If you have a horizontal
pressure gradient, I think you
know what's going to happen.
You're going to set up a
geostrophic current.
A few hours later, you're
going to have a
geostrophically balanced
current, and that's going to
be an ocean current this time.
So that's what we're going
to be looking for.
So the winds over the ocean, for
example, in the Atlantic
Ocean, the winds in the tropical
regions are from east
to west. The Ekman flux will
be towards the north.
Up in mid-latitudes, the
winds are westerlies.
The Ekman flux is toward
the south.
The Ekman flow is going to pile
up water in the middle of
the Atlantic.
And then with that high
pressure, you're going to
generate an anti-cyclone in
the way of ocean currents
around that going in this
same direction.
And for years and years, the
theoretical oceanographers
knew that that little
variation in sea
level had to be there.
But finally about 15 years ago
well, more than that now we
were able to measure this for
the first time by flying a
satellite in orbit and having
a laser point down from the
satellite, bounce it off the
ocean surface, time how long
it takes to get that
signal down and
back up to the satellite.
We were able to measure ocean
height for the first time
within a few centimeters
of accuracy.
Then for the first time, we were
able to actually make a
map of this tiny little
elevation
in the Earth's surface.
And here it is.
It's called Ocean Dynamic
Topography.
It's given in units
of centimeters.
And for example, when you see
red here, the water is piled
up about that much.
So you wouldn't ever notice
this if you were sailing
across the ocean.
Remember, the ocean's five
kilometers deep.
What does 40 centimeters mean?
But this is relative to the
geoid, relative to a constant
level surface on the ocean.
And it's that piling up then
that gives rise to a pressure
gradient that then causes
the major ocean
currents in the ocean.
We're out of time, but this will
be the theme on Monday.
We'll talk about how these
currents get moving.